thank you to Harry's and expressvpn for
sponsoring more on them after the Rea
show citizens of the reject Nation Andrew Gordon
and I have been having such a fun time covering
these guy Richie films and we are doing the one
easily that the comments have been requesting the
most it is called the Andrew aka the gentlemen
Andrew how excited are you well all right all
right all right I'm excited Greg I know it's not
as good as our STM uh impersonations I'm really
excited just from all the uh doing a pervert
what was that I if you know what a pervert
sounds like you tell me but anyways I excited
miror from all the comments we've interrupting
you thank you cra I appreciate it's not easy to
keep going while you interrupt me but from all
the comments we've been getting on the request
uh for this specific guy Richie film I'm super
excited and also two from the last guy Richie
films we've done I really love both those films
so I'm extremely excited for this one looking
forward to it guys is this your favorite guy
Richie film leave it down below are you excited
for the Netflix series that we just learned was
coming out when we were trying to find out where
we can stream this leave it down below leave a
like subscribe and click that notification Bell
to get notified when our reaction for a movie is
up in the channel you're like yeah that sounds
like my jam also thanks to prepper for helping
us edit down these highlights and thank you to
all who have been joining us on this Miraculous
Journey at our patreon on page becoming super
sexy rejects over there you get the full length
reaction where you can sync up with your own copy
it's a full length Reaction watch along and we
also cover several things over there exclusively
with highlights and watch alongs included lost my
my breath there was swallowing my spit it's
a Monday that we're filming this let's do
it whoa this is weird now the movie starting
over the Studio logo I like that always stylistic
choices with kyi Bobby what I have a pint in
a pickled egg up it's a very specific pickled
egg order you know Matthew mcon doesn't wear
deodorant fun fact is that true true yeah his
dad said he should smell like a man oh okay gry
ah good catch made himself an Easter egg if you
wish to be the king of the jungle I do it's
not enough to act like a king okay you must
be the king don't wear deodorant don't fake it
till you make it don't deodorant there can be
no doubt because doubt Causes Chaos in one's own
demise that's cool interal narration that he was
actually thinking it wasn't just a narration
for the story I love guy Richie style I really
I really Do's got such cool variety he really
does stay night tonight 9:00 you and I River
Cafe who's there Roz who's there oh [__] whoa
my what what a reveal at the beginning I mean
they're probably going to do like a of course of
course but knowing the whole film that's going
to happen oh my God got some major nonlinear
storytelling to unfold Charlie Ham's in this
cool Henry Golding this like a bond open
yes right this a cool cast man
and Hugh Grant Man from Uncle he's
back guy Richie he always picks such I
mean it's early on but he always picks
such good songs in his films it feels
like it's going to feel a little bit
more like the guy Richie that when he was
first came onto the scene with a gangster
films wow this looks like an
Ikea a commercial in Britain or
something
fler I've got a meeting on Saturday at your
favorite newspaper I love the voice he's doing
they are ready to put 150 Grand in my pocket to
give him some filth good for me that but in this
case it's bad for you oh it's fun seeing him play
a character so big Dave editor extraordinaire has
developed a terrible antipathy for your boss he's
out to destroy it we both know that your boss has
very very deep pockets and I would like to invite
him just to have a teeny rumage in them ah what
the [__] are you talking about furnish me with
20 million British pounds I will give you memory
cards contact sheets recordings the lots and a
modest little screenplay Bush that's a steep ride
R in 30 seconds that you're lucky because that is
nothing compared to what I could be asking thank
God you're not greedy Fletcher you deluded [__]
eating jeez quite like it when you talk dirty to
me I can feel myself in ging drink with me it's
really yummy loving the sex oh man I imagine he
had so much fun getting a chance to really step
out of what he normally does you play a game with
me B I don't want to play a game please no I said
play aing game with me R oh cool great editing go
from far away and then close up on those two lines
and back and forth here I want you to imagine a
character a dramatic character like in a book or
a play or a film but not digital analog chemical
process keep the Grain in the picture I say old
school 35 mil are we watching it I was wondering
if lot right when he said it yeah I'm seeing this
through a lens I am and I'm not talking about the
small screen it's not TV Raymond as I said old
school right okay is this guy Richie talking to
us yeah R camera so cool enter our protagonist I
had a okay he's gorgeous he's Golden Age he's a
proper handsome his name is Mickey Pearson the
betterness of this American Born Road scholar
so he's born clever but poor I relate but he
never finished his education because he found
his vocation a naughty vocation he's a bad boy
that substance looks familiar he starts stealing
the dirty Wonder weed to his rich British upper
class uni Pals ah he's an entrepreneur yeah man
drug dealer entrepreneur what's the difference
he had to do some naughty things to get where
he got to establish his position to become king
to show he was wasn't just teeth tits and tan
well he wasn't fing H was he oh he had an engine
under his hood and in his holster machete does
not look real well that was the early days and
he cracked on with his new world Pioneer Spirit
what's he worth today 100 200 500 million I
wonder if in person I would be able to keep
up with everything H Grant is saying like can
you put this in subtes while you're talking to
me cashing his chips and get out the game and he
seems to have found the perfect customer smash cut
please has been cultivating a special relationship
with the erudite learned and broadminded Matthew
burer I do know about the Jewish billionaire
Cowboy Jewish billionaires Matthew Burger
blindsiding us with his donation to build
the entire cognitive behavioral therapy unit
he sold him some weed earlier they've done some
small deals together they for the big one now I
understand why you're seated at the head of the
table Making a Splash with the Gentry oh I like
to make a splash whenever possible understand
the significance of a proper attire I believe
a sense of ownership is vital in every aspect of
life perhaps never more so than when it comes to
wardrobe represents who you are and for every
season a strategy now starts the alpha dogs
they're not really talking about clothes Raymond
I know they're like a pair of old doggies sniffing
around one another's intellectual [__] it's a
good oldfashioned cough Rond it's fun how he's
letting us know we're watching a film itself like
it's very self-aware in that sense and it's like
his gangster film with but upper Society you see
try as I might I can't work out how you do it and
Bush is my game how does anyone grow 50 tons of
Super Skunk without letting anyone else know how
they do it lots of practice 200 million gross
PA 100 mil Jesus your people know this already
they've s the numbers for months now I got to
get into a life of crime seriously right we're
wasting our time in here it was Big Dave he
commissioned me to do a job on Mickey you know
sniff about keep an eye on him go through his
bids reveal his sins good bars is that the Lord
pressfield is Grace the Duke yeah once full fin
line to the throne apparently Mickey pearon has
squeaked his way into the crack of his fat Posh
ass I need a man with your creativity with your
nose now you know you're my favorite blood ant I
love how animated they get when they curse I've
learned off you lot you got to look after number
one and now's my turn sun is not going up for me
Ray it's going down I feel like there's such a
fascinating history to hug Grant's character two
months ago your man Mickey made my man Dave feel
like a right idiot didn't accept his hand Dave
had gone after one of Mickey's Lords it would
appear that his lordship had had a quick spin
on one of his attractive young footmen after the
splash shares crash ah sorbing again Dave will
do a feature on him but you're Mickey he's got a
fabulous set of balls so he snubbed him in front
of a crowd that Dave could only wish he belonged
to you know Lords and Ladies the sort excuse us
oo there is a reason why Matthew cannot work
out how Mickey does what he does how does he
grow 50 tons of white widow Super Cheese every
year that needs a lot of space so where is the
space who does he bribe I want to know you have
to be be creative you need an angle problem with
land in this country is there's not much of
it and there's Public Access even when it's
supposed to be private and the public have
rights dog walkers yes y on right to roam
bimblers Ramblers Badger lovers and any other b
c with enough time on his hand the structuring
you have to do in the editing room for something
like this yeah I a nightmare you must remember
that cash is very persuasive to the class that
got spanked by Angry lefties and death duties
and every time you inherit a fortune you lose half
to the state mhm and offer my services so they can
keep their houses in order and they're not too
bothered about what I do as long as that cash
keeps rolling in each year 12 sites you a dirty
12 Farms 1,000 of these Estates in the great UK
interesting my infrastructure that sir is with my
blessing what you are paying for wow what a cash
flow but enough foreplay Michael I want to see
your plant if you were standing on my bush you
wouldn't know it it's like everyone's talk here
is sex in some way they're not talking about sex
but that is their language in the entire time
sexual innuendos delightful tool shed for $400
million Ooh La La this is
connected to all the homes
jeez this is my dream it's fake YouTube location
staff technology so you're buying the substructure
for the super structure to come imagine they
used mirrors to make it look like there's more
so funny Matthew MCC has played this guy did you
know it took 15 years after alcohol prohibition
ended back home for the legal Market to scratch
that itch H mhm I mean Mar is becoming more and
more legal yeah and I'm not greedy you and I both
know that 400 million is a fair to generous asking
price I mean you'll make that back pretty damn
quick 200 billion and well half a trillion pounds
annually the legacy of these customers relying
on illegal marijuana White Widow super cheese
it's the new Gold Rush this is the thin end of a
very fat wedge sir I don't know what the laws are
and then London cuz like in California be like
yeah it's complet was it's legal out here yeah I
have no idea what it is out there an Enterprise
like this we'll need a face with the clean past
exactly yeah we both know growing is only 50% of
the business I need your European connections I've
seen how the sausage is made now tell me about
the butcher shops well that comes later Matthew
many miles away another beautiful feral Beast
Lopes his way to a watering no I talk Rondo of
what is he Chinese Japanese panes get on your
[__] knees Jesus yellow is a color gambling
is a God oh God like a millennial crack Oh Henry
Golden Henry Golden usually plays like such swab
elegancy dry eye like a Chinese James Bond harass
to kill that's the one I know right there more
like this RAC to kill yeah it's an old school guy
Reggie not afraid to make his characters racist ow
him down load him up and come off yeah this guy
usually has such a great err about him debbon
air quality it's kind of I'm excited to see him
play more of a gangster criminal rle I quoted you
for a 20 when it's a 40 footer it's going to be
double bubble double bubble a gentleman's quote
is a gentleman's word o I would not cross this
guy it's not to be trifled with well your family
are going to have to pay for that lesson do we
have an understanding just say yes just listen
man you don't mess with snake eyes if you're
thinking of smoking that here don't I find
that confusing do you mean don't smoke or don't
think both you know exactly what he means oh he's
really serious about this it's going out it's
going out this movie is about illegal marijuana
how funny I think the time has come for me
to introduce you to our Queen scatter and
cigarette van the only weak link is his devotion
with his beautious lady wife this is a sanctuary
for the ladies where is he it's up in your
office of the oh my God his car Shop's so
woke so what do you think ringing the bell
but not too loud dipped in noney that's on
the money so this is what we call focus group
guys what the is going on in here I should have
known it was you behind this Rog is supposed
to be working down there and you're up here
blowing his brains out he works better he's
going to be he's going to have so much more
attention to detail or he's going to totally
botch it one of those two one of two if word
spreads that you're getting out that could read as
weakness so you're going to have to stamp that out
without any gentrification don't you do anything
messy that's why you've got people remember she
is so lucky why are you wasting our time I know
what happens in my my world and what doesn't he
stepped outside you can smoke the cigarette I
blame him I would want my spelling why Michael
should be motivated to write you a check for 20
million I am a Storyteller there's any chance of a
stake all right I haven't
either it sounds good I'll
guess it mate oh no you're
all right just stay right
there m it's hot he's a Sly Fox that Fletcher
indeed oh oh my God looks like a young Valk
kilos night night asan oh man I thought he was on
the straight and arrow I didn't I didn't think he
was going to be uh I thought he'd be like oh the
the good guy you know you got all these parts on
a 40ft container how'd you get your hands on that
ask no questions and no lies so what surprise I
mean with your husband that's not going to happen
keep the PS consider ajust your Goodwill I like
what he's done with his teeth yeah dry he got his
it sit down with Michael didn't he unsanctioned by
the dragon head himself Lord George but dry ey oh
he's next generation and them chinen they upgrade
quicker than I big man PR behind Lord George's
back to be fair is very nicely played with 100
Grands worth of free car parts cuz everyone knows
that the way to a man's heart is through his wife
it's true heyen I would like you to consider
an offer well let me stop you right there this
is not a discussion for the two of us unlike
the salt and pepper it's not on the table this
is a big number is it more than 400 mil when is
enough going to be enough well you only verbally
agreed to the other guy right gosh I am not for
sale I want to know how much it's on there even
if I was you're several zeros short now you may
be able to buy a man sausage for that but to me
it just looks rude at breakfast you're have touch
you don't have to be so rude to this guy now when
the silver backs got more silver than back he
best move on before he gets moved on it's not
dignified beneath you Michael trying to do you a
favor are we supposed to suspect that it's Henry
Golding who got him killed oh at the beginning
yeah there's suspects and this oh this is a big
gun w w oh oh jeez eyes not so dry now are
they hurts does it looking for your a hole
in the wall was this was this the right call
there's only one rule in Jungle damn when the
Lion's hungry he eat I don't think it was
Henry Golden I think yeah I was wondering
like I don't know this character entirely
but it seems out a character that's not
how Michael works yeah I know no I know
he's just having a bit of fun well we did
see with the machete earlier on but just
didn't go that far every movie needs a bit
of action doesn't it and it's not like Michael
doesn't have a reputation reputation he's been
gentrified here oh okay never mind could be
him they need a little bit of action for the
movie was a young and foolish Dragon who
came to ask a wise and cunning lion about
acquiring his territory now the lion he wasn't
interest said so he do the little dragon off
couldn't understand off me persisted and
continued to ask the lion about acquiring
his territory so the lion took the little
dragon for a walk and put five bullets in
his little dragon head oh Jesus now allegedly
there's a message in there I don't know what
it is but you're a clever boy dry eye if you
can explain it to me so you're saying you'll
sell Mickey was pleased he took that meeting
wasn't he yes it went very well things started
to unravel after that meeting didn't Mickey
get a rat infestation at one of his Farms
o oh oh was like those are GoPros they got
on going to mess up his operation it's not
going to be worth shnit no no oh they're
going to destroy everything he said to'd
be a bit of puff yeah they weren't joking no
don't do it the fu are you not cover do you
know who owns this Gap he doesn't even see
the slightest bit nervous what's this Teddy
Bear's Picnic just one at a time you that's
fancy a warm up for you JY bab three Lads
three Colin
Ferell why you smell a we in here now back
two steps Tri you're on you you're up he
warned you he oh you're going to stop stop
trigger don't you know dance what he is like
a Four Tops tribute actor something putting
the gay back in Marvin Gay I'm on fire over
here let's come on I need some back and
forth come on I need some back and forth
make it funny you that's not funny this a
point no no not that go again me with it
D oh
oh [__] slapping them now wake up Lads Lo
quick you're slow Lo hard in a bone top come
on down the gym we'll see what we can do with
just I'll Mentor you guys are you the coach
coach is earning he is the coach coaching
for Ernie what is it balls in the back of
the net I'm going to include you you're our
Mentor well I don't know what you're talking
about but I don't like the sound of it you've
landed a load of sticky Bush oh walk away it's
too late we're at the gym now I'm loading the
van you took my van we'll be back in 10 minutes
I think you need to see this boss oh my God col
Pearl is going to be the best part of this whole
movie they uploaded a video crazy picking
up dra plants not 10 or 20 gentle I never
get cracked man's his legs nothing like posting
a crime you just committed oh damn oh oh damn
right right ear oh no why are we watching
fight right because it's fight at one of my
Farms making a rap song out
of oh I assume he knows who they stole from
yeah yeah know he knows put down that box of
scorpions follow Jim what might be coach so is
this operational like train kids to become like
boxers but also to make them a part of like
gangs like it's like a gang at the same time
is the front a boxing gym or is like it's it's
all rolled into one I'm already so fascinated
by what this is 1.9 million hits in one night
Nikes I mean a real fight with a music video
it's dances come on would watch it what I think it
is yeah the best version of it tell me you didn't
put that fine no what was I thinking leaving
your kids alone supervised it's your fault take
it down now I've got to say I was impressed
they're on point Governor what a fun mislead
because it seemed like they were going to whoop
their asses that's great mislead who'd be smart
enough to find one Mickey's farms and who would
be bold enough to make such a move especially to
film it all and then post it all online because
that is really rubbing your face in it isn't it
is that the guy he works for f Grant I hear
you might have had a little trouble now you
helped me before when my source ran dry so I'm
just returning the favor it's a paper weight to
keep down all the paper I'm about to give you well
it looks like a gun and it's a paper weight it's
noisy Cricket bad timing jeopardizing deals
shutting down Farms it would be an expensive
disaster if Mickey doesn't get this cleaned up
all right cuz if you don't pay means I'm going
to have to close shop well I'm not going to
pretend that missing out on a million pounds
commission a year isn't going to hurt someone
I've just learned we need a whole new roof
apparently just there's such a quirkiness to some
of the like the real world stuff they include and
when it rains let me take care of the roof that
estate roof though that be so much money yeah
those aren't cheap and they cover a lot of ground
Dave is going to bring Mickey down by using an
abusing Lord pressfield's much beloved child
Lord pressfield's daughter has fallen for this
power Noel smacked out dark charm unbridled
by distractive parents too busy skiing on a
Swiss House to notice and too [__] stupid to
care jeez junkie Bic autotune singing daughter
shacked out with some smacked out once upon a
time pop star and all after by Mickey Pearson
I like we miss her terribly Mickey I failed as
a parent she was particularly vulnerable only
she had better parenting or betterhelp.com good
pluging she's gone missing they've asked us to
find her bring her home well I had a feeling you
might ask me this boss whether some due diligence
I know where she is oh she's on a South London
Council estate so tell our jurisdiction I mean
what if she doesn't want to come it's going to get
messy well that may be true but you're still doing
it but can't you send Fraser instead no I can't
send Fraser instead you're my best man I want you
it's tough being the best man this is where you
step on stage and set the Domino's flying every
do you think Charlie HUD him killed him it's
very ambiguous but like that we're asking these
questions do you think it's going to be revealed
or are we just not going to know I think it'll
be revealed we have to know so disappointing
if we don't know yeah that would be too no I
just need a moment of your time it's about Laura
pressfield I don't know anyone on that night sure
course be much easier for all parties concerned
if I could just step inside for a moment no
off the
[__] as you was boys and
girls why does that actress look so familiar
I know I've seen her in something maybe it was
Spider-Man 3 I can't remember I work for a man
a powerful man Michael Pearson who's Michael P
friend of her fathers runs London's buff game
the anomaly knows oan where are you from I'm
from Narnia Disneyland that's close now Laura
father's asked us to bring you home she's not
going anywhere why you just shut up man seriously
just shut up you know you're not in control of the
situation do your moment out of favor and try the
impossible make yourself happy all right that was
easy it's a [__] hole anyway hey there's no
need to be disrespectful don't go please wait
cut his head off touch me again I'll cut you
on oh man dude he's scary he's got such a calm
and soft demeanor but then he can come off in 180
scary in si keep the kids in school for one minute
I love all the subex St oh I think it was that
guy was in the freezer aen no there it is oh no
oh oh they going out off the
balcony oh what have you done oh that's not a
gun dear that's a paper weight of course it is
along with a family of six baby bullets I
mean there's some serious consequences to
that uh she might need some rehab though
one of her Associates had an accident fell
out of a window boss oh [__] or not the car
stream accident yeah more like a death really
head is depart moment oh no who was he some
Russian kid with tracks on his arms Russian
kid that doesn't sound good maybe someone
related to him is what yeah gets Matthew
MCC Yep this is not ideal Oh I thought
it was a head there was his whole body
there lson we're going to need those phones
clean nle come on and catch me little oh no
no gangsters proper naughty boys and all that
bollock I come in peace I'm not trying to steal
it I'm trying to buy it good money honest money
honest money what this one how much full bag
and I'll be gone wouldn't kill a kid how about
you give us that bag and be gone anyway oh
oh God kids don't poke the Bear right hey oh
I love how they all ran and he stayed although
he would have shot him if he ran so it didn't
matter put the phone on the ground there's
such an intensity to this movie there's a real
tension well done I had no idea that gun the whole
time did you no to reveal call him somewhere I'm
trying just give me a second what are you do can
I use your toilet is he okay to give this kind of
information to him I mean he could wipe him out
at any second well the the shoot the information
could be elsewhere be other traces and stuff
that's true can't just kill them [__] you
say come on you say oh oh great St work there
phone damn Hugh Grant you are an amazing tracker
Story Time over is there a problem here Ray I
don't know is there a problem here Fletcher no
no problem no problem at all yes I forgot to wash
my hands it's funny cuz it's more akin to like
the stuff he's done and stuff like Lock Stock
and snatch but yeah stylistically it actually
feels more grounded than those where those are
a lot more flashy in it's editing and execution
I need that Chinese Gaz address okay love it
morning coach good luck find out his weed we
took and now you tell me uhoh this is not the F
time to keep your cards close to your chest just
tell me his name is Mickey Pearson BL me coach
you're a gypsy too been reading tea leaves got
a crystal barall that is not good news AR Mickey
Pearson is terrible news in the face of aoid an
expensive death so many options son who offed him
I think it might be Charlie onam I think you're
probably right but I still think it could have
something to do with that aen guy who can't wi
off the balcony it really feel like that's going
to come back on that note I'd like to extend my
apologies on their behalf my boys they're naive
my responsibility so it's me that should be
accountable for their actions so I offer you my
loyalty until that debt is settled you ceral is
the [__] I love him in this I'm going to need
to know how your Lads got the information about
where our farm was cited once we've overcome that
little challenge then we can talk oh man charlot
home is excellent too because he just seems so
welcoming but he's so intimidating when it comes
time for it the acting in this is is really good
his name is fak sp with a pH so it sounds like
FW
F we've met before haven't we
Fu [__] that's the one [__]
[__] how did you know the location
I've been dreading you for months R
was given the address I can't breathe I
need that please all for hook for hook
down it's so like unexpectedly
funny man here take a blam now
good boy no no sh the inhaler we know
these guys are not good with their
cardiovascular the buildup of this room because
this just going faster and faster could just be
dry I doing it's been getting bold lately yeah
well they still all work for Lord George it's
like a tumble weed effect of just Gathering more
and more crap and problems it just keeps getting
bigger and bigger and faster there's a lot of
emphasis on how scary Mickey is but we really
haven't seen Mickey do anything that like scary
other than what didn't happen in that one's action
sequence they're more focusing on the intellect
of him what you watching I'm watching the horse
teally the profile shot of him but his back's
turned to the camera from Hong Kong my only Vice
well that's not strictly true is it meaning
I've always taken Vice to be the definition
of any criminal activity involving prostitution
pornography or drugs very fiscated I facilitate
I don't participate in any of the aforementioned
devices well Justified what about te what about te
well that too is vice C caffeine is a drug don't
you know so is that what you're here to talk to
me about sweet Mary Jane is my VI of choice as
you well know of course I'm addicted to selling
it not consuming it okay Matthew we got here deal
in marijuana sure I could see there was more to
be made and Shifting the white or the brown powder
as you so chose you see my jam it it doesn't kill
anyone your poison is and always has
been the the destroyer of world up
inimer oh no what this woman do to herself
she's about to oh no your facilitation is
most definitely participation yep
but I'm not here to give you a
sermon on situational ethics why the
are you here what did you put in the
tea oh going Exorcist here burn it
all down you're starting a war with
me George and I'm trying to moonwalk
with Elegance here but I'm finding
it very difficult just when I said we
haven't seen Mickey do anything that
scary you didn't think I'd find out having
me followed for months you raided one of my
locations you know the rules George oh
God you thinking you raided one of my
locations I think this is the same composer
Wrath of man as like the Menace is still
there such a sense of a dreary tone always
in this film yet it's like fun yeah yeah yeah
yeah for sure it's like the two guy Richie
worlds we've been introduced to lately I can
see you're feeling somewhat under the weather
because I spiked your tea with a nasty little
parasitic genus called Chella I suggest taking
two of these fizzy biscuits you'll be fine in
an hour or two long enough to consider your past
indiscretions that would be one way to go on the
[__] get to you in your own kitchen I can get
you anywhere surpris Let Him Live did you raid
Mickey Pearson's Farm uh-oh so you're telling
me that [__] did this behind your back well
let's just say this he didn't do it in front of
it but you did go behind my back and offer you
buy his business I don't see this ending well for
Lord George there comes a point where the young
succeed the old dude you're going to get you're
going to get murdered right now there's something
I don't know about something between dry eye and
Lord George we're coming back to that scene at
some point whatever it was someone killed Lord
George anyone else might think that was you or
Mickey I know the way guy Richie works at this
point does that arouse your interest Raymond so
Matthew no's dry eye oh interest interesting
you play dry eye I should be Matthew try and
get it in time with his lips all right roll Camera
Action that was like a perfect cut and edit right
there wow this is called el football there
was an incident Lord George excite rymond
spit wooden the last thing you need to
do is attract in the octopus octopus
what does that mean it's not a very good
translation no there's nothing wrong with the
translation Matthew's not that fluent and it's
Cantonese Just go with it and fill in the legs
and there will be repercussions for Michael's
actions you think you're running th do you
don't stroke my mouse hair yeah I think what he
means is don't jeopardize my deal but I admit
that one's a bit of a googly I've never seen new
grand transform into a role before this is real
this is how it's going to play out I'm going to
back the off and I'm going to take it all and
you will you seen coro's there's elements of car's
waed this I I never saw that one I know 1993 Brian
De Palma dry eye I trust you will make Michael P
pay for this the Russian no solidify your position
you'll be done Uncle never mind definitely
not the Russian oh this is it oh from the
beginning Hey it said g Richie yeah maybe he
was a mislead maybe he wasn't actually shot
maybe the other guy got shot oh then hearing
someone there tipped him off that he was going
to get killed we're close hang up no hang the
phone up who's that oh is that uh dry eye Raz
who's there what you doing Charlie yeah at this
point I'm guessing that you didn't even know that
Lord George was dead yet let alone what drye
was up to hello dry eye what do you want it's
like those slippers FY B sweet so yourself the
gun right there yeah the gold gun what Charlie
Hunter must have got him yeah yeah exactly yeah
that was that's what I what I said that just a
little bit of go you're not listening you're two
into the movie and I'm sorry what did you say
I know but I heard you but I had to like see it
first good call though he's not picking up maybe
you should put your seat Bel on yeah let me call
Ros let me do it got to imagine the adrenaline
is going crazy right I love how he protects
him so much could just slow down a little bit
oh oh god really feel the impact of that oh
[__] and Guy Rich he had that so in frame
for a good five to six seconds to come
with me or Tony here he's going to make
you come with me you're in my office under
my roof it's not your position for Tony to
do anything other than off back from Wy k
I love her what's that is that a paper we
funny should say that turns out anything with
weight can be a paper weight either you do as
I tell you to and use the door or I'm going to
shoot Fat Tony right between the eyes you see
this gun's only got two bullets so I'm not going
to about illustrating its significance T get on
it ooh right between the eyes I thought he was
being tortured for I didn't
realize he was still in the
car Nikes yep you dead man I dare you just
calm down I'm leaving oh same spot damn she
got a great shot she's so hot there only
two bullets guess that's your two bullets
he didn't she isn't there six two she said
there's two where's all the other employees
oh what the hell man hello
Bab oh you are so
done [__] should have left when you had the
chance so you're basing your whole Crescendo on
a figment of your imagination I'm basing my whole
Crescendo on the some of its parts unreliable
narration you are too smart to be blackmailing
us flet yeah that's what I'm saying so I've taken
precautionary measures you can do all kinds of
horrible things to me if you want I might even
enjoy them Matthew he's going to need some people
to run his business here when he buys it from
Michael right he promised dry the job that's what
that's what I said it was Matthew who told dry ey
the location of Mickey's Farm exactly he's the
only one who knew the location but what he did
not plan on you see was dry ey W one step ahead
killing Lord George now dry eye does not want to
be subservient to Matthew anymore doesn't want to
be subservient to anyone oh damn there is Henry
Golden plays such like a slimy ruthless character
everyone so many people are playing against tyer
I'll tell you how this plays out you will drown
and then my mad crabs will eat you this is and
this is why I want my hard ear 20 million because
not only do I know how Mickey's business operates
but I also o know that the very man he's trying to
sell it to is trying to force him into selling it
on the chap yep that if anything happens to me I
I do have my insurance policy in place everything
will go to Big Dave from him to the public and
you my love will go to Mars strong recommendation
just pay out you seem terrified right now man
20 million we got 72 hours starting now tick
tock tick tock I would have blackmailed the the
other guy um what's his name Matthew it must be a
h Grant roll on missing because this is the person
I really feel like I'm not watching hug Grant he's
just left he thinks he's very clever start with
Big Dave o someone else is watching Can't par
there mate move the van don't worry friend we'll
be gone in a minute we're on news Paper Blood SP
so is John Claud vanam I'm warning you rust does
karate he's like do I careful boys B do karate you
know what go for you get in the car sorry boss
I'm only a blue belt you melt I come back when
I'm a brown belt we're making a YouTube movie hey
break dancing I warning you powerful we know all
that how you tell us all about it in the back of
the van just go in the van man they just kidnapp
him not masked up at all out front here you're
all right Big Dave you're in safe hands now no
need to panic now in due course we're going
to press the space barar on this computer oh
no we're going to post this online the
only thing you need to do to stop this
little creative expression from becoming
a social media sensation lose any interest
you have in the future on Mickey pears
black Mir him oh my imagination's going
into 10,000 different directions oh I would
even want to watch thatd say you win would
you want to know the truth want to know
just his reaction that's all I need to
see it wouldn't have been the pig I would have
chosen is that who I think it is
yeah certainly is that'ss you're
doing I've got one more thing I need you to
do ah look I train lads to be good lads I'm
not gangster I've been forced to do some gangster
things I'm not the gift that keeps on giv so with
the greatest respect I'll do this one last thing
for you three strikes no mail like the genie three
wishes that was a guy Richie referenced you
totally missed yeah it's true dude freaking
caller Char H are the best parts of this movie
and he's barely in the movie he's amazing are we
ready to finalize the numbers we already have
the Situation's Chang oh you pompous little
punk I hate this guy so much oh he's so smug
you're asking for 100 for 12 locations and a
distribution Network which was a fair valuation at
the time H your skunk Farm was a viral sensation
on YouTube Michael yes I follow it will take at
least 3 years to get your supply distribution
and demand back to full capacity oh my God I
calculate what was worth 400 million a month
ago must now be valued at an anemic 130 it's not
about the first Domino that it fell it's about
the last I have a feeling we're going to get
a great monologue for Matthew mccon I'm hoping
so if you want me to help you out of this hole
you found yourself in the the one you dug him
in yeah I like your Domino analogy the question I
ask is who tumbled the first Domo amen that's not
my concern or my business Michael at the risk of
contradicting you it is very much your business
only made one mistake you seem to have mistaken me
for some kind of let me introduce you to the first
Domino recognize him who is this man what's
he got to do with anything that I'm talking
about show them the picture of them together you
are in denial of so said relationship with this
Frozen China man I don't have relationships
with dead Frozen chinen best not to be GLI at
this time in the proceedings Matthew I'll tell
you how this plays out you will drown mic drop
while you were discussing who would take over my
business after you it you somehow mistook so said
chinan for someone else it's nothing personal
and while I am not emotional St up there is a
price indebted to me for the blood I've gotten on
my hands restoring order to the untidiness that
you created yeah 400 minus 130 is $270 million
and 670 I'm keeping the business ooh are you are
getting in the freezer oh [__] [__] that said
I wouldn't about cuz frostbite is very expensive
on the fingers and toes so I would type as quickly
as possible while you have the use of them oh my
God there's your monologue as stated I am not
emotional about the money but I am emotional
about the fact that someone laid their hands on my
wife Fair Deal oh man dude that was rough what he
was about to do no amount of money on God's green
earth can pay for that trans speci Matthew no for
that o take something from it I want to pound a
flashh it matters not to me where on your animate
is withdrawing from ooh but oh my God Penny short
or a gram shy another pound that freezer door does
not open am I clear good he's a master negotiator
there's your payment come on take a look all the
files everything your insurance policy all the
photos all the bodies all the skeletons all the
filth it's not the only one darling I'm not among
what you think in that need you I knew you'd been
following Michael very similar our jobs only I'm
better at it than you are God I love these gy
Richie reveals got some very important information
to impart to you Raymond when the scotch got into
your cold veins you lost the benefit of your sharp
instincts see I kept you there cuz I needed to
know about Matthew and dry eye smart took us
a while to find your insurance policies shoes
off inside but it was made a lot easier after I
planted a Tracker in your shoe ah now Fletcher
what were you saying it wasn't Lord George that
was after Mickey or drye or Matthew it was uh the
guy who they threw off the balcony some someone
related to him my guess at least 30 seconds thank
you darling it's got to keep it's got to come
back right yeah we're going to take care of
this for you Ernie's got a plan you talking about
what the Michael situation we're going to S it
what oh no now you remember asland don't you no
dude you got it well this is Asen senior Russian
oligarch oh I had a feeling that was going to
come back I had to yeah you're right and I fear
that where they failed before Raymond they're not
going to fail again again how' you know all this
because someone told them everything they want to
know about Michael and that someone is me ooh so I
said I'd tell him where Michael was for a price
but that money was pending till after know the
deed was done should have shared that information
see get my 20 Ms off Michael first after the event
get paid again double bubble why did you just
look at your watch well it's like I say the
Russians are going to clean house and you are
part of that house Raymond they're going to get
Michael when he comes out of his meeting oh [__]
by telling you I've saved your lives which I think
in turn saves mine doesn't it saves stuck a b
him Jesus is there a bomb in the car or what oh
crap damn damn it and he did not like order that
hit on that kid too that was just an accident that
sucks oh the kids said they would
save him though and they had they owe
him oh hey there you
goas Bren
break oh they going to crash into
the car they have to yeah they're
Square love it love it so the todlers
spray the car with bullets killing the
Russians selling in the film I love
it he's going to get his money he
start to guy Richie so he Airport
please terminal three who's in the
carard Charlie ham yeah yeah well well
well a man of many vacations ain't
you now I want you to play a game with
me Fletcher you like games don't you if
you wish to be the king of the jungle it's not
enough to act like a king you must be the king
there can be no doubt because doubt Causes Chaos
in one's own demise yeah my queen told me that
can't no put the camera back in the other room
damn oh boy what a ride big thanks to express
vpm for sponsoring this video a real game changer
I've been using for years that's right years so
whenever they want to work with us it's an instant
yes you've likely heard about Express exess VPN
for online privacy and security but there's more
to it than that however there was a very real
incident recently with Spectrum showing down my
internet and contacting me due to a suspecting
hacking attempt and funny enough I realized I
hadn't actually activated my expressvpn on my new
laptop that I got a couple of months ago so I was
paying the consequences having faced a serious
hacking issue on YouTube a couple years ago that
made expressvpn my go-to for both security and
freedom I mean it and yes what you've heard is
true believe me this channel knows you can use
expressvpn to watch movies and shows on Netflix
that are not available in your country this means
accessing a vast rate of content of over a 100
countries like a global Cinema your fingertips
it's super easy open expressvpn switch locations
refresh the browser and there you have it whether
it's kdramas on South Korean Netflix Hulu BBC I
player YouTube or more expressvpn has you covered
and it's incredibly fast ensuring no buffering or
lack for smooth HD streaming it's versatile too
working on not just computers but phones media
consoles Smart TVs and more this means you can
enjoy your favorite shows at anywhere any screen
protected and elevate your internet experience
so if you want to get access to hundreds of new
shows use my link expressvpn.com reject and
you can get an extra 3 months of expressvpn
for free that's expressvpn.com rejects so head to
expressvpn.com reex to learn more thank you again
thrilled to be partnering with a brand I've been
using for nearly two years now and that's Harry's
Razors I'm generally more drawn to anything that
goes against the norm and Harry's does just that
in The Grooming World they saw the high prices in
the industry and decided to blaze their own trail
with quality and affordability I keep a beer but
whenever you see these cheeks in the neck clean
and that's the work of Harry's right there keeps
my wife happy and Harry's makes it effortless
their Precision Blades that cut smoothly with
less drag making every shave satisfying and yes
it's versatile for other areas too you know what
I mean so as a Harry's devot I can vouch for their
value you can experience unparalleled comfort and
quality in your grooming routine or exceptional
craftsmanship meets affordability making a smart
choice for a top- notot shave without breaking the
bank their kits and value packs for shaving are
unbeatable but Harry's is not just about shaving
again they offer top quality thoughtfully designed
grooming products including shampoo conditioner
and amazing body wash without the premium price
quality affordability that's a thesis of this now
these I actually pulled right from my own bathroom
I regularly use their five blade razor with a nice
weighted handle and their foaming shave gel man
this that oh it is a GameChanger I just like the
feel of it now I have to commit to keeping this
in my hand the whole time cuz I'm not going to
go to the bathroom in the middle of shooting this
the handles they feel perf perfectly balanced and
the razor Sleek design is a classy addition to my
bathroom and the quality of the shave unparalleled
got to reiterate keep part of my weekly grooming
ritual cuz their entire range of products fits
seamlessly into my routine definitely no re-shoot
here their German engineer blades are durable
and refill plans are economical rarely use the
word economical but I'm using it now plus their
commitment to high customer satisfaction and
no risk trial makes Harry's a Nob brainer this
Gel really does feel good let me say once more
choosing Harries means quality and affordability
by grabbing your $13 trial set for just $3 at
harry's.com rejects you're not only getting a
great deal but you're also supporting this Channel
That's harry's.com rejects for your $3 trial set
stay sharp and embrace the extraordinary with
Harry's till next time reject Nation till next
time I can understand now why we got so many
requests for that one I mean that was old school
guy Richie new school guy Richie but there was
just so many different things but I loved all the
stylistic choices as we always get uh the reveals
that later come on uh my favorite part of the at
least per I mean all the acting was phenomenal but
I freaking loved Colin Ferrell so much and Hugh
Grant that was just one of those roles were like
I could just close my eyes listen to him and I
would not hear Hugh Grant in any way shape or form
um but the storyline was so interesting I love it
was very easy to follow and I love just you know
the I just thought it was really cool um just you
know trying to the whole thing of just like the
whole King theme and all that but also to like the
whole idea of um you know uh with I believe his
name was Michael where he wanted to buy it for a
certain price then he hired uh dryeee to drive
the price down and then you know the whole the
whole way the story was structured with Hugh Grant
and again the reveals that later came on it just
so damn well executed and I freaking loved it uh I
got more to say but what' you think I thought that
was a brilliant brilliant film all around um hold
on one second guys if you're listening this in app
Spotify we just watched the gentlemen uh I just
want to check out some some things here okay so
Ron tomato is saying may not win a riter director
guy Richie many new converts for those already
attuned to the film makers Brash wng length
the gentleman Stands Tall I don't know I feel
like this is actually a pretty solid guy Richie
introduction film yeah I think it's attainable
for anybody because the movie is very like it it's
got all the wit of the things you kind of grew up
loving with guy Richie because there's like Studio
I mean it's mirror maximum so there's a studio
element to it because yeah like the the films that
I saw of guy Richie you know growing up like most
people uh were you know Lock Stock and snatch
and the films that we watched are not at all
like those lately right the last few films if if
watching Sherlock Holmes watching Aladdin and then
watching uh you know Wrath of man here and from
Uncle and while wrath man deals with criminals
it's not you know gangster cool it's V and revenge
whip snap dialogue of of this movie I I feel like
just had such a a wonderful blend of Personality
great characters messing with structure in the way
how guy Richie likes to mess with structure uh it
keeps your mind kind of guessing you don't realize
how invested you are in the characters till
they're on the verge of being killed or like oh
[__] I actually like this guy I don't want them
to die you know cuz that's usually a question that
happens with me for films is like how emotionally
invested am I in the characters a lot of times
when I when I find them in positions where they're
about to die are like oh no and then it feels
exciting when they are about to be saved and it's
it's a and like like like guy Richie films of the
before you know a deal with criminal gangsters and
and you know criminal underworlds this is the one
that deals with a higher class of them like a
higher sophistication Mark whereas before it's
like kind of like low-level gangsters you know and
and the Mucky grimy Parts bare knuckle boxing and
whatever you know thieves and here because he's
got like probably more of a of a budget and the
experience you're dealing with like Aristocats
and you know you're dealing with a whole new
class of of of characters yet it still has got
whoa whoa Andrew yet it's still got this like
rounded Focus uh throughout with um a lot of just
exciting turns and points because those movies are
I find them really fun Lock Stock and snatch and I
I think they're like incredibly entertaining with
this one kind of gave me a new kind of tension
like those are so stylistically cool and I love
those I really love those two films but here I
I found myself engrossed in in the suspense a
lot of the time and the tens and then the the the
the unexpected laughs that would that would come
out via through the characters and the back and
forth uh this felt like a world like he built a
world here and I was very surprised by uh how that
world was done because I didn't really know what
we were walking into I kind of expected to feel a
little bit more like the the guy Richie that when
he first came onto the scene um but it's also like
weirdly not as flashy as I thought it might get
and terms of just the direction it's more flashy
in the writing you know whereas I think with stuff
like Wrath of man and Man from Uncle that we
watch it's more flashy in the direction and I
think here like the writing actually speaks a lot
more volumes than the direction like they're going
around there's some like cool flashy stylistic
direction that are happening throughout um but
it's more um it's more the the writing of the
characters a lot of that really uh sings the
most of me yeah no I I I agree I love that dream
very suspenseful tone while still creating a fun
environment and uh also to uh just piggybacking
off what you said with it the direction um I love
how so many of these characters like you know
you get this calm uh demeanor from a lot of
these characters but like in they can in a split
second can just get extremely scary on a dime um
I mean you even said too there was a sequence
where you're like we haven't seen a Matthew MCC
scene where he gets like extremely intense and
frightening and then boom right then and there
it's like guy Richie was listening to you um but
I I I like that uh when charact because I think
that's more frightening when characters can
seem very calm all throughout you know a film
and then in any flash or uh instance they can just
frightening come out of their shell if you will um
so I really appreciated uh the direction from guy
Richie in terms of performances I really liked uh
the actress who played Matthew mcc's wife like she
was able to from an actress point of view she was
really able to stand to uh you know on the same
toes with Matthew MCC and I just especially for
a very masculine movie yeah for sure I just love
the interactions between them like they were just
so opposite of each other but they were also
so perfect for each other like the king of the
jungle and the queen I just I loved all through
interactions they were so good yeah man yeah I
think like this is a great crime Caper with a
with a with a fascinating sort of like a bit
of a flamboyant touch I would say you know what
I mean yeah like especially like the Hugh Grant
character the the Matthew character I thought it
was excellent and what I what I like to in terms
of casting Grant it's like I haven't seen every
call and feral role I haven't seen every um well
more so I haven't seen every Hugh Grant role and
I haven't seen every Charlie hunm role but usually
from the roles I have seen them in especially
Hugh Grant in particular where even watching
him a Man from Uncle you're like yeah it's like
more sophisticated Hugh Grant you know yeah yeah
usually Hugh Grant is just uh Hugh Grant to me
like I always like watching him I always think
he's a very Charming guy I think I think he's a a
star uh but he's usually just Hugh Grant and here
really stepping out of his El he was a character
like he was a full-fledged character and I I loved
uh the way he changed his Cadence the voice it was
very believable sleazy um you know another cunning
character here like guy rich is great at at at
illustrating characters who are cunning but then
ju supposing it with um a character who I feel
like might have gone to like a Vinnie Jones back
in the day uh Colin Ferell I think might have been
like a Vinnie Jones kind of character totally that
of this guy who's like well yeah he gets he rides
the line between like you know like the world he
inhabits and the and the streets he inhabits have
gangs involved so he will like have to once in a
while participate with the gangs but he himself
is not a gangster you know and but wanting to be
a mentor for the kids as well I I thought was a
really like that whole introduction scene where
you just think he's going to like beat the [__]
out of these kids and then it just ends with him
saying come on the gym some like so great and
he just had like the funniest lines and the and
Charlie hunam especially too I thought played um
he had that kind of like Elegance about him but
he's got that loyalty of like a Brad Pit to George
Clooney in the oceans movies you know uh that
kinship between them seems like their bond extends
further past this is just some guy he works for
but the movie does doesn't you know shine a
spotlight too much on that it's just right I
think everyone's CH like to hear that this this is
getting a series I don't know if it's just in the
world of the gentlemen if it's these characters
of the gentlemen with new actors I don't know what
they're doing with that series but I like I said I
think here he he did build a world and this world
is one that seems like a great one to like dabble
in and it is super super masculine film but hell
yeah man I'm here for the super mascul Kai Richie
never really makes a movie where it's a and I'm
super appreciative of the fact like that he can
subvert our expectations so much and again it's
not subverting just to subvert but he does it in
a way that's very satisfactory and IT services
the story and the characters and it's just so well
executed when he does it and it's to the point too
when you can rewatch these movies and go ah okay
like you can pick up on things um and also too I
got to give Matthew mccon props that monologue at
the end uh when he was calling out Michael uh you
know like saying like hey how you you screwed
over the deal and then the froz of China man
thing and but when he said like the whole pound
of Flesh thing and then like my wife and then he
got in his face freaking powerful acting I mean
the acting in this film was just top freaking
Notch I mean Charlie hunm scene too with the kids
and pulled out that machine like where where was
he hiding that thing How It Ends in that with the
machine gun but but when he's first taunting them
cuz at first I wasn't sure about the Dynamics I
in the beginning of this journey I wasn't sure
like okay am I not going to be on the same page as
everyone who's recommended this movie because I'm
not exactly loving the way that because it was a
lot of information to kind of be keeping up with
like it's throwing you into this world and it's
turning off into Mikey's perspective yeah and uh
it's going by pretty quick in a way where you're
like oh you got to keep up with that guy Richie
you know energy and pace and eventually I'm not
sure when it was when it was like oh I'm really
starting to like a Groove I'm vibing with the
movie now you know cuz it is like a dance this
film and you got kind of like as an audience ever
got to you know Dance w your way with the film
as well and and there was a I don't know when the
when the when the Pivot Point happened for me when
I really start to like it because because in the
beginning I was a little unsure of like am I not
going to love this in the same way how I feel like
people might expect us to love this movie it but
once you attune to it um and you and you really
get a sense of of the style yeah and the fact that
it can be yeah British banter with some fun plot
twists all the all the minations that you love
of a guy Richie experience yet with um I think a
I mean he always has heart that's another thing
too you know like I think a lot of people often
compare a guy Richie is like oh you know he's
British Tarantino I think he's a little bit more I
don't think he's that like I see the similarities
of course especially with this one with that has
so much cinematic references throughout in the
Cinematic uh metanis which is something I going
to say I love that so like Tarantino especially
loves to call attention to that in a lot of his
films and I don't really associate guy I see Guy
Richie pay homage and tribute I don't really
see his characters unless I'm just completely
forgetting I don't really hear his characters
often do that where this was so about that you
know from this unreliable narrator standpoint of
Hugh Grant talking about pitching a film ending
with pitching a film that gets so met by the end
to the point he said mirax yeah you know uh which
I thought was really fun and cheeky and but in
a way that I think complements the experience of
this movie and and so I I understand when people
compare like him to Tarantino but I don't feel
like I don't feel like they're they're one and the
same honestly I think they're very I think there's
so much differences between them and especially
in like the mood and the editing style whereas
this is a little bit more of a patient version of
I would say of it's still fast and energetic it's
I don't know if the it's a slow it's not as not
as fast as like a snatch or a Lock Stock I would
say but I wouldn't call it slow either whatever
the word is to make me sound smart put that word
there apply it here and Tarantino is usually a
lot more deliberate regardless and and I think
guy Richie is is much more tuned to like yeah you
know writes for the edit in a lot of ways and as
usual I mean the nonlinear storytelling just again
very meticulous and very well executed because
you can really screw that up with bad editing
and not you know putting it in the right spot
so I thought it once again like he clearly loves
going to that technique of nonlinear storytelling
him and Christopher Nolan clearly love that angle
and again if you're gonna do it you got to do it
right oh my God and Henry Golding as well another
guy who play I've seen this guy in two movies we
interviewed him once for Snake Eyes oh cool um and
Snake Eyes which I know didn't get great reviews
really nice guy we talked to him he was really
funny called John and I he said we look like J
silent B really yeah he said look like you guys
look like especially the time when we interviewed
him we had longer hair and bigger beards I did too
and he he's like you look like the funniest thing
I got to watch that interview uh yeah so we got to
meet a really nice guy and uh you know we saw I he
did that some Christmas movie with Amilia Clark
I forget what it was that Christmas movie Crazy
Rich Asians most people know from that love them
and the guy wasn't even an actor he was a host and
he got crazy Rich Asians now he's found himself in
this world of acting and I love seeing him play uh
so against type like I think he did something with
his teeth cuz I'm pretty sure the guy's Perfect
Teeth yeah and and he he embodied like a nastiness
and I loved guy Richie you know casting actors who
kept playing against type like Matthew mccon was
the probably the only one who did what I would
expect Matthew mccon to do he does a great job
he's great in the movie like he's very he's just
unbelievably natural at it at the same time you're
like yeah I don't know anything about this movie
yet this is exactly what I expected from Matthew
MCC in this film uh just that suaveness that Deon
Aire quality that he brings uh yet you know he
could be like a total badass slick monolog the way
he carries that dialogue with that southern charm
uh yeah I thought he was excellent but everyone
else the cast of characters that were surrounded
by were they all played so much of them played
against typ just did something I hadn't really
quite seen before like Colin Ferrell has done such
a variety of roles that I wouldn't really call it
like against type uh but hug but definitely yeah
yeah I I was very much a A Dazzle by it yeah I was
not expecting that from Hugh Grant just cuz I'm so
used to seeing certain type of roles from him and
like I said if I closed my eyes and was listening
to that voice I would never say that's Hugh Grant
so I mean I was like you said his character was
completely fully fleshed and I really loved him i'
probably say him and Colin Ferell were my favorite
in terms of characters in this film but all
the acting was superb in this I mean I watching
Charlie Andrew I'm paying for two and a half hours
give me like 10 more minutes of you okay all right
man all right yeah it stays in the video let let's
do this just going to talk about the gentleman
point I'm done talk I don't even want to talk more
I'm just going to make up [__] to talk about
all right let's do it what we got to talk about
Charlie hunam what you think oh I this movie was
making me go I would love to see Charlie hunam
and Colin Ferrell like not just oh yeah that's
a great wish uh but but to do a movie together or
or like to Star the next guy because even though
they don't have a lot of scenes together they had
that impact when those two were on screen yes of
this chemistry that I sort of felt was unmatched
between anybody else it's like Charlie hunam is
usually paired up with Matthew mccon here but
there was something about the Dynamics and the
chemistry between those two characters and the
way they Rift off of each other a lot of times
in just Expressions that they would kind of share
uh to each other that I thought M that that really
made me go wow I want to see these two characters
come back or I want to see them staring another
guy Richie film together or starring something
together because uh their chemistry to me had so
much conveyed and communicated when they weren't
even speaking a lot of the time yeah and they were
the two that I thought did that the strongest out
of this wonderful Ensemble of characters yeah they
only had a couple scenes together but yeah the way
they were emoting in their face Expressions it was
just like so infectious to watch I just yeah for
sure and I love the unexpectedness too of like the
gangster children like the kids you grow up in the
Rough Side of the these streets and they but they
kind of you grow up in these streets you find a
way a life of crime that's kind of like the where
where you get the guiding Mentor role of Colin
frell coming in who wants to steer kids clear from
that like I said there's it's it's grounded in a
world but there's also World building you know and
Greg they gave us one of the greatest rap songs
ever put on film yeah Oh I thought the unexpected
Ed I said that was great because when they're all
coming in one at a time at the marijuana Farm you
you're thinking they're all going to beat up these
kids yeah yeah with like one gu coming in after
another like all right they're about to get the
crap beaten out of them and they play the footage
and you find out never mind that's not the case at
all again that's KY Richie's Style Just revealing
something later on love it oh no this is a very oh
I think it's a sequel show uh cuz it's following
a guy Eddie halad inherits a large estate from
his father unaware it was from Pearson's drug
Empire huh yeah oh oh John Carlo Esposito's in
it oh as a criminal oh so yeah it's got to be a
sequel show that makes I'm more happy about that
I'd rather watch that than a remake yeah yeah of
course and Guy Richie is involved I would assume
but even that with like these Estates who are who
who who keep the cash flow coming in Via this
illegal weed Market uh dealing is is a really
uh compelling again World building that that it's
like so I was going to say even if they didn't do
the sequel series I would have been fascinated
if they even if they didn't get Matthew MCC back
like you could have casted a younger version
just showing like how he came up with the whole
IDE even though they kind of showed that in uh
just what he was talking about with uh Michael
I believe the character's name was or Matthew it's
hard for me to wrap my head around because Matthew
is is not Matthew mccon he's the flamboyant
the guy who dicks him over yes correct um but
I mean that would have been interesting but again
just continuing on that that whole thing with the
Estates and all that yeah that's so compelling and
fascinating itself that I think that warrants what
they're going to do with the series and yeah
that fascinates me enough to want to continue
on watching with that I think that's a the smart
way to go story-wise holy [__] okay fun facts
time Hugh Grant filmed the scenes of Charlie
hunam in 5 days he had to deliver over 40 pages
of dialogue during this year Jesus 40 pages of of
dialogue five and with that tough accent too whoa
that's not easy oh they didn't even Grant never
met Matthew mccon dur they didn't have any scen
they didn't have any scenes together Raymond's
Grill was designed by Guy Richie cool wow so much
of the are about uh Hugh Grant yeah uh Hugh Grant
wrote a cheat sheet the night before he scheduled
a shoot his car was broken into the robber took
his script and the cheat sheet so Grant needed
to go without them damn that's that's not tough
oh guy Richie uh is wrote the TV miniseries yeah
yeah oh sweet that's what it said was Guy Richie
working at um you called that one Richie Brewery
you called that one actually is this and its own
by director guy Richie oh okay oh funny I just
thought that was him just putting his own I me
I think the company is him Richie yeah oh funny
there were no table readings for the film so like
guy Richie had the cast do full rehear rehearsals
with multi-angle camera more more natural that
way Richie with then review footage of the scenes
and revise the script accordingly oh brilliant
brilliant like I said I think it came out more
natural that way I mean I think when it comes to
acting he knows how to cast he knows how to cast
he knows how to get his I think that's why actors
you know even though some of his films can get
like mixed review like reviews from the critics
actors come back to work with him for a reason
yeah no I have not seen again I I I didn't really
watch Aladdin I or I watched 10 minutes I didn't
give it a chance but every film I've ever watched
of his act actors wise and acting performance and
directors wise I've always thought like I've
Loved all the performances I've watched for
sure so I can see why like I would imagine being
on a guy Richie said and working for him they love
working with him and I see that Henry kaville is
about to do another film with him yeah it's true
I think T is coming out uh guy or it's out by
the time this video drops guy Richie has a deep
interest in fashion and was very concerned with
the Wardrobe for the film concerned I'm concerned
about the way the Wardrobe is going down to
prepare Charlie Hunter for his role roie took him
clothing shopping to get a feel for his character
and it's funny because part of the script is H is
about uh you know the the importance of wardrobe
uh very early on in the story many of Michelle
docker's monologues were written or Rewritten
on the day of shooting she had mere hours to
memorize changes before Jesus I can't even imagine
how tough that was oh Kate Beckel was originally
cast of the roll of Ros that's that's the wife
right yeah yeah I could I could totally see her
I I still think Michelle Dockery did fantastic but
I could totally see K andell doing that role the
track suits for front of the gang were custom man
the F the attention of fashion here very important
sting we just talked about I accidentally
mentioned sting right before we started
filming too though never mentioned the
movie fans found an Easter revealing
Fletcher first name to be Peter at
around six minutes in the cover of
the screenplay Peter Fletcher can be seen
in the bottom left corner ah that is a funny
reference working Tils were tough guys
and Bush no the gentleman it's more
Universal his charact rant said
his character was based on General
SAS uh okay I've try to see there's any quick
F fact no not as fun not as fun not F we got to
watch Legend of the sword oh King ar oh wasn't
Charlie hunam in that one yeah he plays King
Arthur and like you said actors love coming back
to work with G Richie Gotta See Brad Pit come back
to do another film with gy Richie that I want
to say it's usually like the A-list um you know
white guys who don't come back Matthew MCC Robert
Robert Downey Jr Brad Pit like now we're one and
done sorry buddy remember D he came back for the
sequel well I mean other than a sequel we're one
or two and done with you after that he's like no
never mind we're too famous we got [__] to do
um but yeah man I would give this oh music great
everything great always picks out great songs in
his films I mean he can do no wrong when it comes
to the music I can't wait to see the show I hope
the show's good if he's that directing it do
I really want to watch it though I feel like
his voice is part part of the voice of it is
his Direction yeah as long as he's a Creator
and a writer I'd be fascinated just to take a
look at it at at minimum I wouldn't I wouldn't
be surprised if he at least did an EP I mean
they said it was eight episodes so I wouldn't
be surprised if he did an episode I probably the
pilot yeah I mean even Tim Burton did like what
four or five episodes of Wednesday and he's
about and he's doing Beetlejuice too right
now so yeah got to imagine he did at least
one I don't know but I mean as long as he's
writing creating it I'm going to at least have a
look at it for sure cuz I was just so fascinated
by this world it must mean it's a big film yeah
yeah I loved it uh guys what do you think about
the gentleman what would you rate it down below
is there anything in here Andrew Before I Let
You Go that you think you did not like or could
have been improved uh hard to say right now but
overall um no it was Prett for the most part I
loved it um another great guy Richie film uh so
far I have not seen any films of his where I did
not like I just love his stylistic choices I love
non the way he utilizes non-linear storytelling
those where he comes back to reveal things uh
subversion of expectations uh just really solid
director I love the comparison you made uh in
our Man from Uncle video where he obviously does
not get the recognition and I'm not saying he's
as great but he's really damn close in my mind
uh to Christopher Nolan I know take that with
what you will um but you know uh I just really
big fan of his and I'm so glad this journey we
getting to go on watching his films he's damn good
yeah especially terms of precision and calculation
of how he how he does things you know um yeah
they make very different films but yeah yeah
of course of course all righty guys thank you
for being here and uh we'll talk with you all
soon